allora ragazzi grazie a thomas abbiamo
scoperto che chi non lo sapevo neanche
c'è un segreto in tappe è come cara come
si dice sto gioco ancora che forse per
la mappa ci sono 10 micro mostri di loch
ness micropop sono piccoli sono
bellissimi e gli devi sparare addosso se
li ammazzi tutti 10 in un certo ordine
sono sparsi per tutta la mappa e da un
batterio ial quindi difficilissimo
trovare tutti i pezzi intorno alla ma
perché c'è gente che ti mena ci hanno
provato io tom e pietro insieme siamo
riusciti a farci al primo tentativo per
sbloccare il segreto vi lascio al video
perché veramente figo bayern paga non so
se è veramente difficile
guardate in alto a destra nel colpi da
fare un essi c'e scritto appare un messi
è vero ce l'ha scritto che dai dai
ragazzi dai poco a ma non lo vedo ma è
sott'acqua o lo vedi comparire l'oro è
un piccolo peluche verde ok allora vedo
semi spuntano eccolo lo vedo cioè 4
perfetto dove l'amore allorché la che
aspetta aspetta però lancia liano
shuriken andare al serio è morto volo
shuriken ok 4 andate al 5
vado al 6 ciò che trattano mozambique e
per fare faristi qua o tre colpi esatti
per i tranesi che ci sono allora
dovrebbe essere il 7 esattamente qui
sotto a meno che non ci sia ancora
qualcuno aiutare speroni ha mai preso un
sacco di siringhe l'ora per curarti per
carità questi link e niente ciò 10
secondi tom dei miliardi 10 secondi
nell'acqua nello stagno di fronte la
quale 10 secondi 10 secondi 10 seconda e
all 89 87 65
dov'è la trova equa dovrebbe essere qua
non lo trovo raga non lo trovo ve lo
giuro allora mi dice che quando è al
pintore paga vi giuro
sono qua non c'è a meno che non sia
dentro la casa aspetta dentro una casa
sul letto quello sul letto era classe
pezzente ok ma vai vai volevo 10 10 10 e
non posso vederlo è già fatta
hai fatto il nome l'hai fatto nove
ragazzi di the promuovere ad arrivare lo
guardiamo tutti insieme
provaci provaci arrivare proprio
arrivare trovate il 10 intanto arrivo ce
l'abbiamo fatta subito ci credo che
l'asp ha ancora detto
10 mi dice che è qua ping praticamente
no non sono sicuro per il 10 di gara ma
non aspetta su un albero sotto delle
fasce a bordo 6 cioè a bordo ma fa
proprio ne devo andare via di qua
curatevi raga e passiamo allora prendi
qua
eccolo eccolo lo faccio fuori però lo
faccio fuori aspetta aspetta se accurata
di cura di se potete più dai tamil ok da
milo che lo faccio fuori ma trasmessa
sta arrivando dai dai cori paisan sono
lontanissimo st arriva arrivando parlava
sparagli ci sono stati voi a fare o
nessi e appare un messi che senso guarda
guarda varela o mio di miramare
ma è rocco non aveva così è fighissimo
chiami social lo vedo chiarissimo dove
si anch'io vedo strà chiaro perché c'era
la 6 pochi ma è lui che figata soci
sciolta a tutti quanti veramente no
sarebbe stato un bel finale e se ne va è
apparsa e se ne va che figlio affiggerla
che li tra andiamo a prenderla bene se
la mia ci metta è stato è stato
bellissimo della mia non c'era tutto sto
casino quindi ci sono le in essi che
sparsi in giro perché ti fanno comparire
il mostro di loch ness
questo è fighissimo stava ci stava di
andarla a vincere se magari se la vinci
ha ragionato con ciò perché non ci
arriviamo con il mentendo inserito
madonna siamo ancora note no ragazzi
simili che male sono morto bison siamo
stati morti ma non versa voglio morire
vicino ha detto vai pietro pure due
bellissimo bellissimo veramente figo è
stato molto filmato figo molto film 0 da
anni ma tanta gloria che i ragazzi era
un po corto video scusatemi ma questo
era un segreto molto figo da far vedere
ho intenzione di fare su apex solo
vittorie praticamente quasi sempre solo
vittorie
domani arrivano le prime due vittorie
niente spero che vi sia piaciuto come se
al momento non mi piace anche ai soci
alcuni descrizione ci si chiede come
sempre xetra vasti di telecomando ci
vediamo alla prossima vita da ragazzi
[Musica]